um I have an entry in the global startup
battle and I'm trying to get votes
without buying them I need a thousand in
the next two days is there anything I
can do so this comes back to how do you
sell a book you do it for nine months
before it comes out yeah but you didn't
really have a week you've had your whole
life and so you know to me to me the
answer is so yes but not social media I
would tell you to look at things like
Outbrain where you can buy distribution
I mean if you are you talking about
spending money I don't know we can't you
can't you're not allowed to you know not
you know not from us I don't know in a
week nothing nothing I talked about
could you well that's not true you gotta
pick your 30 actual friends so in the
same regard you might not have built the
following but hopefully you've built the
network the relationships so go call and
leaned on heavily a group of individuals
that have some extant that was the first
thing you did you already did that of
course if like any contest that that's
why I said nothing even asking first
move did you ask Li do the ask it's
there's nothing more frustrating me and
when you do this broadcast emailed all
your network and you say will you help
me and nobody does because they don't
know that you are or not
up in the other hand you actually pick
up the phone that's exactly right you
work through the process of what they
need to do and then ask them they
wouldn't mind reporting what they did
you might actually get some better
results yeah I did that for about ten
people but I could keep going yeah you
know to you know this they flipped for
both of this whether it's personal
relationships in the real world or
whether it's what you're building is a
following in fans it's build it before
you need it and I'm gonna just jump on
that a little bit really go for the
right hook like of those ten people go
look um listen I did this for my new
book I have so many friends and
contemporaries and acquaintances that
write books or have Kickstarter's and
they may and they blast an email and I
don't feel personal with that I'm like
they sent it to everybody so I literally
emailed one-by-one talk about it sounds
hard the email was contextual hey how's
Sally hey saw you at the Padres game I
mean it work like eleven minutes per one
email or four minutes per and they
converted and then I got real gangster
because I'm so obsessed with this book
I'm going back now being like hey Carl
you didn't buy or blog or talk about my
book and then I come back two weeks
later be like Carl so of those ten of
those ten people did four of them do it
did seven of them do it did all ten and
if all ten didn't go back to those two
and be like I wasn't joking this is my
this is one of my asks that I'm gonna
have in my life that's that's the that's
the jab jab you have asked and you
really are allowed to do that over here